hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
linear dna improving
raav production and synthetic dna i'm
susie valdez of labyrinths and i will be
your moderator for today's event
i'd like to invite everyone to
participate by submitting your questions
during this presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation
simply click on the question mark icon
on the left toolbar for further help or
submit those questions in the ask a
question box so let's get started
today's webinar will be presented by dr
jude somolski the president and chief
scientific officer and co-founder of ask
bio dr samolski received his phd in
medical microbiology and immunology from
the university of florida his graduate
work demonstrated the first
use of aav2 as a viral vector which
accumulated in the first usa
fda approved gene therapy drug for liber
congenital amaurosis typically referred
to as lca
now dr samalski has worked with aaz for
40 years and has advanced therapeutics
in human clinical trials for hemophilia
muscular dystrophy giant axonal
neuropathy pompe disease and congestive
heart failure
450 articles and holds more than 300
patents related to aav technology for a
complete biography of dr jude somolski
please click on the biography tab at the
top of your screen dr smallty welcome
you may now begin your presentation sir
thank you see very much appreciate it uh
it's a pleasure to be here today i
will take about 30 minutes to walk you
through a innovation that we think is
going to be impactful for the production
of recombinant aav vectors
i'll start off with a little bit of
history the level said everybody
as to the topic and where we originated
from a number of years ago and it'll
bring you into
focus with respect to the problems or
the concerns that have emerged
as this technology has been marching
into the clinic and then hopefully leave
you with a expectation
of what's likely to come based on the
synthetic dna approach i want to first
mention that lester suarez was
the proposed speaker today and he was
not available because he was getting
this kova shot so as a result of that
i'm going to step in and
assist with his presentation
so i'll first start we're giving you a
brief introduction of the history of aav
av was discovered in the 50s in an
attempt to identify what was causing the
common cold
and they were isolating and no viruses
from the adenoids of patients
and were interested in generating a
vaccine that could be used to protect
individuals events
and as you can see in this magnification
the small particle there is actually an
av particle advance
that was eventually discovered based on
the life cycle
and utilized as a
method to determine that it was an
independent virus advance
as you can see in this cartoon it's
about a 20 nanometer particle compared
to the 100 nanometer adenovirus and it
ended up being a virus that was
non-enveloped and carried a
single-stranded dna genome
advanced
here's a cartoon illustrating the aav
life cycle on the right hand side you
see what's referred to as the lytic life
cycle and if you advance
you can see that in the presence of
adenovirus both viruses will infect the
cell and generate progeny however if aav
infected a cell in the absence of
adenovirus as illustrated on the left
hand side
it would be genetic suicide but instead
the virus devised the method of latency
latency where it could persist in a
dormant state however if this cell ever
was infected by advancing
you would see that it would re-enter the
lytic life cycle
and produce progeny so from an av vector
perspective if you advance you see that
what we were able to do in the late 70s
early 80s was to clone aav into a
plasmid backbone and as a consequence of
that if we took this inert plasmid dna
and introduced it into a human cell and
then co-infected with adenovirus we were
able to reproduce all of the steps of
the av replication cycle
so this was the initiation of the aav
vectors and if you advance to the next
slide
you can see a few events one more time
what's basically happening is the in the
laboratory one is able to remove 96
of the aav genes which are referred to
as rep and cap
and replace that with a therapeutic
transgene
on the left hand side of the slide you
can see
an av capsic cartoon and so at this
point the av vector is packaged into the
proteinaceous shell
and it ends up carrying the new
sequences into a target
cell type if you advance
you can see that this was first
demonstrated in 1989
in the paper
published in tom shanks lab at princeton
where we separated the cis acting
elements illustrated by the dark boxes
and the plasmid at the bottom
from the trans elements which are
represented by the plasmid at the top
if you transfected these two plasmids
into a human cell
and once again infected with adenovirus
you would turn on the replication genes
and the capsid genes
and they would rescue the cis element
and package the foreign dna into an aav
particle along with adenovirus and so
these were the early
progressions of
trying to uncover the av life cycle so
it could be utilized as a viral vector
if you advance
two times you'll see that
the av transient at this point
could simply be packaged into any aav
stereotype if you advance advanced
events and events
you'll see that
one has the ability to put av into many
different flavors of aav and if you go
to the next slide you'll see that when
you take these different serotypes of
aav with a so-called reported gene such
as luciferase and inject it into the
muscle of a mouse that they transduce at
different
levels of
of
capability where you see av1 it's much
better than aav2
and if you adventure slide what we
essentially we're establishing at that
point if you advance advanced events
is that
many different genes could be
substituted into these proteanaceous
shells and if you advance one more time
you can see these were basically
building what we refer to as molecular
fedex trucks
if you go one more slide you'll see that
at a little bit later at time in 1998 we
were finally able to uncouple the
adenovirus dependency
and extract out of the 36 000 base pair
genome
4 000 nucleotides that were responsible
for helping aav go through its life
cycle
so now you had three plasmids being
introduced into the human cell
and after 48 hours only one virus came
out which was the aav vector of choice
carrying the therapeutic sequences
so in the next slide
in advance one more time you'll see that
what ended up happening was many many
research groups were beginning to take
different aavs as seen if you advance
av1 for muscle
if you advance you see av2 which was
approved for libra's congenital
amaurosis as susie explained earlier
in a v8 we're being used and to target
genes to deliver all became specific
carriers for therapeutic proteins based
on the
production
systems i just described
and if you advance one more time you'll
see on the left-hand side that what has
happened is the field has advanced
there's many many plasmids that carry
various capsid proteins
um one and no virus helper plasmid and
at the bottom
a plethora of aav therapeutic genes that
are clumped between the terminal repeats
these are all introduced into a
bioreactor
but in essence what we really need if
you advance
is on the right hand side we only need
the wrapping cap gene and the antivirus
helper sequences as well as the vector
so as a consequence what ends up
happening
by default is that we end up with a lot
of the so-called plasmid backbone as a
contaminant and this contaminant has cpg
motifs that are
insults to innate immune response they
carry an antibiotic resistance gene and
they potentially carry neo antigens that
could be problematic
in patients so why do i focus attention
on this let's go to the next slide and
i'll explain
there are basically three things that
seem to impact av production at the
moment the first one is illustrated here
is time and if you advance
you'll see that in order to make gmp
plasmid for manufacturing one has to
establish what's referred to as a master
cell bank or mcb
it takes about three months to do this
and then if you generate so-called fda
gmp plasmid that's about another five to
seven months
if you advance further you can see that
the cost for making this and if you
continue to advance is
hundreds of thousands of dollars per
gram of plasmid and then finally if you
advance in advance again you'll see that
contamination
ends up being a byproduct of this
current method for generating these core
resources that are required for
production so let's go to the next
flight and ask a question
why is there contamination
in the aav preparation and i'm showing
you an illustration here of a cartoon
that shows the aav inverted terminal
repeats illustrated by these t-shaped
hairpin structures flanking either side
of a reported gene and in the bottom i'm
illustrating on the left-hand side the
contamination of plasmid sequences
inside of the virion compared to the
therapeutic vector on the right hand
side and you can see we get anywhere
between one to ten percent
of the plasmid backbone is being
packaged as a contaminant
now if you follow
the logic behind the cis acting sequence
or these terminal repeats are
responsible for packaging
you have to scratch your head and say
why is the plasmid
being packaged at any level
it doesn't appear to or should not have
pla terminal repeat sequences and if you
advance to the next slide
you'll see a paper that was published by
my colleague
joshua who was my first student and his
wife john lee
where he was able to show that when you
put in an infectious clone of aav into a
human cell in the presence of add
what actually happens first is what's
referred to as a resolution step
this is where it you get a recombination
across these inverted terminal repeats
and as a result of that you generate two
products an av product as expected with
the terminal repeats of interest
and a plasmid that has a portion of the
aav
terminal repeats attached to it when
these are introduced into the production
system
the aav sequences that are the correct
ones amplify however the plasmid
sequences still carry
aav packaging elements on it and as a
consequence these inadvertently get
packaged into capsids xiao was able to
show this by generating the plasma with
only one itr that he referred to as
double d
and as it resolved itself into a linear
plasmid with itrs on either side
he was able to show that this could be
packaged very efficiently
so we knew the cause
we understood
what the mechanism was the question was
how do we resolve this and get away from
this potential
contamination around this time our
colleagues and friends and elsewhere
beginning to show that when you take the
aav vectors and you sequence them using
next genome sequencing they were able to
show that there was at least between one
and three percent of contaminants that
were showing up and if you advance
you'll
see
that i'm referring to
down at the bottom
a dmd patient today at 30 kilograms
would potentially get about 3 times 10
to the 14 vector genomes per kilo
which is about 10 to the 15 vector
genomes that are carrying bacteria
sequences
and this is somewhat troublesome
if you advance to the next slide because
you'll see that in an example where aav2
is used to put factor 9 into patients
with hemophilia about i mean if you
advance there's about 10 percent of
the
input vector was contaminating with
plasmid sequences so right off the bat
we have an issue although the system was
very flexible and very dynamic and very
quick to change different stereotypes it
presented itself with a contamination
that too today is still being tolerated
by both the regulatory community as well
as the research community let's advance
to the next slide and see what our
options are
the options to solve this problem were
actually done some 35 years ago in a
publication
in the journal virology
in which we engineered a very specific
plasmid that as you can see in the
cartoon
in the middle
that at the very bottom of the
illustration of the itr it was designed
to carry a unique restriction site
this re unique restriction site was pbu2
which did not cut in the aav genome and
if you advance you'll see
that
what we have on the left hand side if
you advance again it's a circle
illustrating where the unique
restriction sites were
and they surgically removed the plasmid
backbone away from the aav packaging
sequences
that's illustrated on this there's a
restriction site a claw one that's a
unique cutter so if you advance what
you'll see is that we took three
different substrates
the pvu2 surgical removed plasmid
backbone
the linear av vector or the circular aav
vector and we introduce all of those
into an aav replication system and if
you advance one more time you'll see the
results of this where it illustrates
very graphically
that the av genome that was cleaved away
from the plasmid sequence
actually replicated more efficiently and
generated large amounts of viral genomes
suggesting that
if one could artificially remove this
resolution step one could generate more
material in the end and basically a
cleaner material
if you go to the next slide you'll also
see on
that slide label back to the future
we were able to show that in this
specific plasmid there was a phage
polymerase origin of replication and
then if you infected these cells with
the phage
you would be able to amplify this
plasmid backbone and that if you
purified it in this case it's being
purified as a single-stranded genome and
digest it with the pv2 enzyme you could
again separate the aav sequences away
from the bacterial plasma
this however was complicated by the fact
that it was all done in the e coli and
generated single-stranded genomes
and it wasn't until on present day
technology that we were able to revisit
this concept and actually utilize it as
shown in the next slide
on the left hand side you see once again
the wrapping cap plasmid illustrated
below
you also see that
when you resolve the wrapping cap
plasmid about 4 000 nucleotides are
represented by the rep and cap gene and
about 3 000 come from the plasmid
backbone
if you advance
you'll see that today
there has been an innovation in the
technology where one can add a
telomerase sequence at the end of the
aav itrs
and as a recognition of the sequence by
a phase polymerase one's able to again
surgically remove the plasmid backbone
from the aav synchronouses of interest
and you ask yourself how do we do this
how it's shown in the next slide
and if you look
c6 nucleotide recognition sequence this
sequence is recognized by if you advance
the phi 29 polymerase and it starts to
amplify on a rolling circle replication
mechanism
a very high fidelity uh amplification
and if you go advance again you'll see
that the protolimerase will then
recognize this cleavage sequence and
we'll cut and seal the ends
as a consequence of that you now have
linear dna that's closed at either end
and then if you advance you can see well
by a cleaning up technology one can
remove the plasmid sequences by dna's
degradation
and as a result if you go to the next
slide you see there's a very strong
product being generated as illustrated
on an argoros gel
this product is the aav molecule with
closed ends and completely absent of any
of the bacterial sequences
now the power of this is that all of
it's done in a test tube and there's no
bioreactors or contamination with a
plasmid at any level
if you go to the next slide you'll see a
cartoon that illustrates the so-called
telomere
a sequence of 28 bases followed by the
itr
followed by the transgene of interest
and this molecule is now linear as i
illustrated in the earlier manuscript
similar to the pv2 digested
aav sequences here we have a linear
molecule that has closed ends and as a
byproduct of that
we have removed all of the plasmid
backbones the so-called cpg islands and
contaminants that one has
become accustomed to in today's
production
if you advance even further
you'll see that by the same mechanism of
doggy bone resolution on the left hand
side if you advance you'll see
the original concept of how av resolves
out of the plasmid and those plasmids
amplify and if you advance again
there's still the itrs attached to the
plasmid sequence and that gets packaged
based on packaging size
however on the right hand side
you see our so-called doggy bone
resolved material and i'm only
illustrating this by showing the right
hand end of the genome
in which the itrs are held together by
this
28 nucleotide telomere element and if
you resolve this by advancing you'll see
that there's again resolution and if you
advance again you'll see one product is
the av genome of interest similar to
what's on the left hand side of the
slide and if you advance again you'll
see the other byproduct is a terminal
repeat attached to this
telomerase element and as a consequence
of that we have basically removed all of
the contamination of the original
plasmid backbone by this in vitro
replication
system
if you go to the next slide
you'll see
compared to the left hand side which are
the original triple transfection helper
plasmas we know of today
we're now
asking questions with the so-called
doggy bone
identical materials just minus plasmid
backbones and where they're being tested
in the bioreactor and if you advance you
can see
the virus that comes out of these
systems referred to in this slide as db
dna versus plasmid dna are generating
almost equivalent if not higher amounts
of so-called aav vector
if you advance to the middle next slide
next
image you'll see a silver stain
illustrating the av
products that are being made by doggy
bone compared to plasmid are essentially
identical and if you advance one more
time you'll see by western blot it's
carrying the av
structure of proteins vp1 2 and 3 and at
the right ratio so from a
a core element that's being introduced
into the bioreactor everything is coming
out identical with respect to yield
quality and
composition
if you go to the next slide it's an
illustration of next genome sequencing
where you can see
the blue color shows the percent of
contamination that's in the plasmid
prep compared to the red sequence which
shows that the sequences completely stop
at the end
where these
termination elements are and thereby
dramatically removing the potential for
contamination as
was illustrated by the cartoons
and if you advance one more time
excuse me
you can see that if you take a capsid
such as aav9 carrying their reported
genes such as luciferase either made
with doggy bone or from plasmid and put
it into a reported cell line such as
hela rc32
you can see on the right hand side of
the slide that within the expected
period of time we're getting
transduction and expression of the
luciferase gene
once again these data suggest that the
doggy bone material is of a higher
quality and potency
if we go to the next slide
this is the same vector now put into an
animal model you're looking at
luciferase expression after an aav a
recombinant vector is
injected into the tail vein of mice
compared doggy bone on the left hand
side to plasmin on the right hand side
and once again
the two
final products are performing as
anticipated again at this point and
suggest that doggy bone dna may generate
vectors that are a little more potent
and this is being evaluated as we go on
so if we go to the next slide i think
what you're
left with as a take-home message is that
the standard plasmids that the field
uses
carries two av rtrs
clone into a bacterioplasmic backbone
requested by the fda to be canonized and
resistant
and that when this is introduced into
the production system one generates the
av molecules whether it's a
self-complementary av as illustrated on
the left hand side or a traditional
single-stranded aav as illustrated on
the right-hand side plus
the plasmid backbone sequence
as a contamination and if you advance
your slide you'll see that the standard
doggy bone
dna
is essentially a linear molecule that
has two itrs on either side of the
sequence of interest
and the 26 nucleotides required for the
polymerase to to resolve and close this
in an in vitro reaction
once again
due to resolution you can generate a
tradition of single-stranded aav as
illustrated on the left-hand side of 4.7
kb or a cell complementary molecule and
at the same time if you advance once
more you'll see that
what we have achieved here is basically
reducing the cost the time
and the
product quality of aav using a synthetic
dna starting material
and so i'll close by showing one last
slide
the conclusions and take-home messages
that if you analyze these reagents for
plasmid backbone
you can see that when you compare the
original approach to the doggy bomb
there
there still is the
ongoing concern of contamination of
plasmid backbones however this is not
seen with the doggy bone since there's
only 56 nucleotides total on either side
of the starting reagent
the plasma production system currently
used requires fermentation and growing
of bacteria on the doggy bone we're only
using an enzymatic like pcr reaction in
a test tube
the time required
with respect to
generating this it takes months to do
the traditional fermentation and
purification whereas the doggy bone is
done within days of two weeks
we also see that the av titers are
equivalent it's not superior to the
plasmid approach and that transduction
at least at these early stages seems to
be generating a much more potent reagent
further studies are being done to
evaluate this
enhanced transduction whether or not the
contamination of plasmid dna interferes
with vectors
uh suggesting a lower transduction
efficiency
and when you look for the denovo genome
there's
no
none in the plasma and then there is in
the doggy bones so what we're hoping to
say
in this
tutorial is that a
new technology has advanced out of the
community supporting research that was
done years ago but allowing one to
synthesize dna in the test tube to
generate all of the starting material
that's required to produce aav vectors
which are seeing
a lot of success in the clinic as well
as
new approaches for treating many
diseases from neurological to muscle
to bleeding disorders and i'll go to my
last slide and stop and acknowledge that
aspire is a wholly owned subsidiary of
bear
which has a
production component called virogen
that's in san sebastian spain that
generates all the aav vectors that are
used in our clinical trials it's also a
manufacturing facility for anyone who
wants to generate aav vectors to go into
the clinic
the doggy bone technology originated
from touch light touch touchlight is a
company in england that developed the
polymerase
manufacturing in e coli and we thank our
colleagues at gene whiz who we
collaborate on a regular basis
thank you and i'll stop there take any
questions
and thank you dr samolsky for that
great presentation we will now start the
q a portion of the webinar and if you
have any questions you want to ask
please do so now just put them into the
ask a question box and click send so
let's get started it looks like dr
samuelski we already have some great
questions coming in
are there any challenges you have
encountered when using rca amplification
compared to bacterial fermentation and
the second part of that question is how
robust is that amplification process
very good question and
deserves more attention
um typically when we do the procedure
today under the conditions that have
been optimized we can generate about a
gram
of the so-called doggy bone material
in about three days time
that is for either the helper plasmid
the antivirus plasmid or the vector as a
consequence of that the footprint is
very small so about the size of an
office is all that's required to
generate these gmp material
and um and it's anticipated that this
will only unscale to a higher level as
we get more proficient in managing the
enzymes in the reaction so it's a very
good question and at this point um the
early days of the so-called bumpy road
problems had been ironed out mostly so
that it had a large-scale production
capability
thank you so much our next question one
of the challenges faced during aav
manufacturing is low vector
concentration does db dna approach
affects the concentration of the
raav produced
yeah so
we are seeing about a two to
three fold increase in the vector that's
coming out of the doggy bone production
it appears that by removing the plasmid
backbone it allows the
production of aav to initiate much
quicker more efficiently and every
genome is participating in replication
so in the end we ended up it looks like
we generate more virus
we've been successful in keeping these
viruses at very high concentration after
purification by our team and aspire and
virogen and so at the moment um it
appears that there is a bump in an
increase in production and it also
appears that
as was illustrated these are identical
to the material generated but plasmas
but seems to jumpstart the whole av
production
uh stepwise because you removed the
resolution step that seemed to be
critical
thank you so much and again i want to
thank our audience for these great
questions coming in dr samulski what do
you see as the next quantum leap in the
gene therapy space
so as you can imagine
there is a significant effort put into
production to one drive down the cost
plasmids today make up at least one
third of the total cost and we think
that the doggy bone approach of the
synthetic dna is going to significantly
decrease that the turnaround time will
also be increased since it takes only a
week or so to generate gram amounts of
your production material
at the same time there's a significant
effort being focused on generating what
they refer to as next generation aav
capsules that are more efficient at
going to a target tissue or being able
to
introduce the gene more efficiently into
the disease organ
however one of the things that we're
focusing on and i think it's an
important parameter is the ability to do
what's referred to as repeat
administration
being able to give someone the
therapeutic as a young adult or an
infant and as they grow older if they do
need on therapeutic levels to increase
based on site one could do repeat
administration currently your immune
system sees the av virus the same
as your body would see the covet vaccine
and it mounts an immune response
we and others are trying to
develop technology that will allow these
vectors to be given multiple times so i
think that's going to be a significant
transformation to the
clinical community when that's
accomplished
thank you so much and we have time for
one more question in the luciferase
expression of studies
why do you think the db dna constructs
yielded significantly higher expression
levels than plasmids
that's a good question and it's a
curiosity that we're still struggling
with
we think there may be less of the
so-called incomplete genomes or partial
genomes that are packaged by aav
and therefore you may have more intact
and only intact genomes
with the resolution from the plasmid
sometimes you get
shearing or smaller dna genomes that are
eventually packaged and they may just be
tighter as av particles carrying the
full length but from an infectious
perspective they're not complete and
therefore the overall potency of the
titer is lower and so our typical method
of using quantitation by genome copies
may be giving us a false impression of
what the actual transduction titer is
and we're still exploring that
rigorously to see if that's what's
happening at these early stages
characterizing doggy bone virus compared
to the traditional plasmid virus
dr zamolsky i want to thank you again
for your presentation your time today
and your important research and before
we go i also want to thank the audience
members for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
i want to let you know that the webcast
will now be available on demand through
april of 2022
we hope you've enjoyed this event
take care everyone and have a great day
bye bye and i would like everyone to
know that lester owes me five dollars in
a beer for doing his presentation
thank you guys
thank you again dr samolski bye bye
everyone good night